I was at Taylor Swift's concert on
Saturday when Selena got up there I'm
just curious as her mom what do you love
about that friendship what I love about
that that friendship is it's so solid
and and with Taylor I feel like they can
tell each other anything and like it
will be an honest like in your best
interest kind of relationship yeah it's
not about anything else and you really
it's like one you just don't find out
here with Taylor you see with you what
you see is what you get she is who she
is and and that's why you like she's so
grounded and what worked so hard and
she's always been there for Selena and
and it's just it's so hard to find
someone who and it's kind of the same
audience and you know and it's so
cutthroat right now that they're they
came kind of I mean Taylor I think had
already really been at a different level
when they met but they come up together
and they just have never parted so to me
that's like a true friendship I love
watching that friendship so much yeah
yeah it is it was really cute because
Gracie when Gracie was born Taylor
bought her like boxes of clothes like
the you know the and they were always
like that all these clothes and they got
sent in two and Gracie went backstage to
talk to her Gracie had bought her a
bottle but to give him back and I was
like yeah she probably doesn't need
these but okay so and she put in mine
she kept saying what was I supposed to
say yeah that's the Fate thank you for
the clothes yeah even though she's like
thinner oh yeah
you
[Music]